we all know gamers along with pretty
much everyone else love to have their
expectations subverted and what better
way to subvert expectations than to
release a retrospective list of some of
the past decades best games
a year after everyone else thought the
decade ended so this video will be a
list of some of my favorite games from
the past 10 years that didn't
necessarily dominate the mainstream
channels
of the gamer sphere now plenty of these
games are very well known don't get me
wrong
i'll be steering clear of games like say
skyrim or dark souls
even though those are some of my
favorite games we've talked about them
enough
now this might end up looking like an
indie game best of list which
i'd be okay with and without further ado
here are some outstanding games that you
very much should play
if you haven't already
to our most famous boulder
okay aldi appreciated that
beginning with the 2020 full release of
hades this list will be going backwards
in time
hades has won quite a number of rewards
and for good reason
the game compiles engaging gameplay a
more than serviceable story
and a whole host of personable and
honestly really wholesome
characters i might be a bit biased to
the setting because ancient greek
anything is my cup of tea
but i'd say the super giant team did a
standout job of making the olympian
pantheon and the multi-leveled
underworld feel like an immersive
fantastical getaway
while fast-paced gameplay centered on
battling your way out of the bowels of
hades equipped with a host of weapons
and run modifiers is without a doubt the
game's focus
i also mentioned how the characters you
get to interact with are well developed
and they really show a surprisingly high
amount of emotional intelligence and
understanding when it comes to the
interactions you have with them and in
dealing with the drama present in your
relationships with them
it was refreshing to have this kind of
character depth in a game not to mention
a game whose primary focus is
hell-themed action gameplay
80s has a lot to offer and does almost
all of it well if you like run based
roguelikes and haven't played it you
should change that
and even if the genre isn't necessarily
your favorite i think hades is a superb
entry point and easily good enough to
deserve
at the least a second consideration
[Music]
uh
another award winner but with an
original console focus as opposed to the
pc centric hades
2019's outer wiles delivers an eerie yet
again surprisingly wholesome
solar system-sized mystery paired with a
fire yet soothing soundtrack
reminder this is outer wilds not outer
worlds which released the same year
and honestly outer worlds would also be
a fitting name for this game
outer wilds features the player taking
the role of a novice space explorer
about to venture out on their first
off-planet voyage following the
footsteps of a handful of other pilots
currently strewn about the system
the real-time gravity mechanic means the
entire system is dynamic and constantly
changing as you pilot your spaceship to
explore the planets and satellites of
the system meeting your fellow
cosmopioneers and
uncovering a mystery of ancient beings
along the way the game starts out with a
pseudo-linear path of clues and tips on
where to go
the player has full freedom to fly
anywhere in the system which really
helps drive home the feeling of vastness
that outer space should always evoke a
handful of times that i've gotten
separated from my spaceship
out in the cold void or on different
planets have given me quite the throat
full of anxiety which i was pleasantly
surprised at to have gotten so invested
and immersed in the space vibes as to
have that physical reaction
outer wilds gives an enthralling mystery
in a wonderful setting
of novel space travel plus some humorous
and empathetic characters that serve as
quite the respite from the bleakness of
the void whether they be flesh and blood
playing some catchy tunes around a
campfire
or just text on a wall telling of their
lives in a bygone time
and a final note to say how the game
concludes on quite the meaningful note
and just reiterate how much i enjoyed
the music
i tried my best to avoid any kind of
meaningful spoilers in this blurb
because there is a lot in outer wilds
that you should only be exposed to
through playing the game
i wholeheartedly recommend this one to
any and all players
juxtaposing with outer wilds 2018's
return of yo bradin is not a game i
would recommend to everyone because i
know for a fact that there will be
people put off
by its 3d one bit art style comprised of
just two colors
while i'm empathetic to those people i
personally really enjoy the aesthetic
most of the time and it's quite an
impressive feat to craft a 3d world with
such a limited visual toolkit
the game has the player take the role of
an early 1800s insurance representative
investigating the oprah din a trading
chip that has returned to port after
previously being declared lost at sea
equipped with a magical compass that
allows a partial viewing of the past
the player must decipher through
exploration and raw logical reasoning
the story of what befell the obra din
it's surprising to have two mystery
games on this list
especially back to back considering i
generally don't play many mystery games
and that is just a testament to the
quality of these games
return of the obradin paints a filled to
the brim story packed with natural
disaster
[ __ ] politics and so much more that the
player uncovers piece by piece
accompanied by jaunty tunes and proper
seafaring sound design
also another setting that i enjoy to the
point of having clear bias for
maybe all the games on this list just
made the cut by having settings i love
if you enjoy or can even bear the
visuals there is plenty in this
relatively quick 10 hour mystery that is
well worth your time
for 2017 we have a tie because i just
couldn't stop myself from including both
games on this list
first up is nier automata a weird
android-based post-apocalypse with tin
can philosophers
and sexy antagonists and protagonists
too for that matter
charming writing and an outstanding
soundtrack are delivered with beautiful
vistas
action combat memorable bosses and
thematic set pieces
despite faults i might have covered in a
previous video i should make it known
that i really love this game
and it has so much going for it not even
getting into the very real philosophical
themes about existence and meaning
like a few others on this list new
automata showcases how art is a term
which can easily find a home
in this medium for the other 2017
candidate we have another game filled
with action combat
memorable bosses and a killer soundtrack
except now in two dimensions rather than
three
this game is hollow knight a
metroidvania extravaganza set in the
remnants of an underground
and dilapidated bug-themed kingdom i
bought hollow knight on a whim during a
steam sale in 2017 when it hadn't gotten
too much buzz yet
and both me and my roommate watching me
play were wowed by the game
an often quiet setting betrays the high
octane and satisfyingly fluid swordplay
and platforming
the game takes you through an
interconnected world with great variety
and level design
emphasizing exploration define new paths
revitalize old ones and
upgrade your combat and movement
abilities there's even a small cohort of
characters who provide some civilized
breaks from the constant hexapod
deathmatches
near and hollow knight are arguably my
top two favorite games on this list and
they achieve that spot by being such
full well-rounded games that simply
excel in their genres
with both 2d and 3d covered you gotta
try at least one of these two
preferably both
trust me
2016's entry while a more mainstream
studio release flew below the radar of
standard triple a's
it is titanfall 2 the second entry in
the underappreciated titanfall series
though with apex legends popularity
maybe not so underappreciated anymore
titanfall 2 adds a succinct and pretty
impactful story mode in the form of a
compelling journey of pilot and
personified machine
in addition to the mech-based
multiplayer formula of its predecessor
titanfall 2 plays like a solid shooter
with an extreme helping of complex
mobility mechanics both horizontally
with slides and hops and vertically with
wall runs and grappling hooks
while multiplayer is pretty limited in
its variety of populated playlists
nowadays
at least in my experience it still
delivers thrilling fast-paced matches
that are relatively accessible for
someone familiar with shooters
but not necessarily familiar with
titanfall the game is also worth getting
for its campaign mode alone which puts
to good use basically the entire arsenal
of mechanics-based tools that the game
features
along with a meaningful if
straightforward narrative if you're an
fbs fan and haven't tried out the series
titanfall 2
is a fantastic entry point and if you've
played apex legends and enjoy those
mechanics
titanfall 2 is a great place to get more
of that content in a slightly different
environment plus a well done campaign
mode
2015 brings mechanical input down quite
a few notches with the horror game
soma which while having some spooky
monster type entities
does a better job of unnerving the
player through its piercing
philosophical questions
of personal identity and selfhood soma
has the player wake up in a mysterious
underwater research facility
and try to survive an array of monsters
while piecing together the mystery of
how they arrived at the station and
what's going on in the outside
world soma is a favorite of mine because
despite being a kind of walking
simulator
it definitely utilizes its medium that
of the video game to drive home its most
poignant narrative themes and happenings
said another way soma uses its gameplay
to heighten and intensify its narrative
elements
the fact that the key elements of this
narrative are philosophically founded
helps too considering my appreciation
for philosophy runs deep enough to have
gotten a degree in the subject
soma encapsulates how great storytelling
can be tailored to uniquely fit a video
game setting
and it uses this tailoring to ask some
pretty insightful questions of the
player
this is a game that i would recommend to
anyone who wanted to genuinely
appreciate how a video game can employ
narrative
and in doing so inarguably become a work
of art
behold i am elohim and i
speak unto the darkness be gone
excess data cleared for 2014's entry we
have the one game on the list that i
haven't actually beaten the talus
principle is a portal asked puzzle game
in which you are guided by the voice of
an ever-present god-like entity through
a series of chambers that require you to
manipulate the dichotomic classical
technological environment utilizing
laserjammers to get around hazards and
acquire puzzle pieces
a more narrative focused game might make
me more trepidatious to suggest it
before i've played through its entirety
but the gameplay focus along with the
slightly eerie setting and philosophical
underpinnings existing more as
peripherals than foci
let me recommend this game fairly
comfortably also you can get the game
for like four bucks on sale
so that plus the fact that it's pretty
overwhelmingly positively reviewed
kind of removes any worry i might still
harbor about recommending it
if a fun set of puzzles plus some
philosophical musings on humanity and
robot personhood
somewhat alasoma intrigues you check out
the talos principle
similar to talos 2013's entry features
an omnipresent voice somewhat guiding
you through the game's chambers but the
relationship between player and voice in
the stanley parable is one much more
jovial and chiding
and literal deity in creation
we went down right left down
left right yep okay okay
yes i've got it now this story is
absolutely
definitely this way
the stanley parable is another walking
simulator style game with relatively
minimal player interaction in terms of
mechanical gameplay
you implement your agency more along the
lines of where you go and whether you
listen to the not really an angel on
your shoulder
this is another game which does a great
job telling its story through its unique
medium
plus it does so with a strong helping of
comedy and meta humor
despite being a pretty short game of
just a few hours it is a blast to play
and something i would imagine most
anyone can find amusement in
2012's entry is dishonored if you
haven't heard of dishonored color me
impressed
have this stealth gamer brtm montage to
get an idea of
to
it
[Music]
[Applause]
basically it's an immersive sim set in a
pseudo-british disease-ravaged steampunk
world in which your character has been
framed for regicide
hence being dishonored while the first
thought that entered my brain upon
loading up the game when i was 12 was
that the hud suspiciously mirrored
bioshock
dishonored offers complex level design
and a varied arsenal of tools and magic
abilities to clear each mission to your
preference
player choice is really emphasized in
this game which kind of bucks the trend
found in other linear narratives of the
same era
slaughter your way to those who framed
you arrive there undetected
or get through the entire game only
using the blink ability
the choice is entirely in your hand when
playing dishonored
2011 the year of the last mainline elder
scrolls game
is now a decade in the past for
something to temporarily distract you
from the fact that tes6
is still probably over 2 years away try
out to the moon a quaint rpg maker game
with an emotional story and a powerful
soundtrack
the gameplay is goofy and not super
existent so you may be misled to not
take the game very seriously
but the narrative and the story will
quickly correct that misguided
assumption
and the sequel finding paradise just
released yes after 10 years a relatively
positive acclaim
to the moon is an endearing adventure
that you shouldn't discount solely based
on looks
and that you should try if you're
looking for something story rich but
easily approachable
and with that we are done with the list
proper but of course i have some
concluding honorable mentions to subvert
those expectations one last time
halo the master chief collection is
worth it just for the huge amount of
stellar single player content but it
also
has a healthy cross-platform multiplayer
population with a custom game server
browser on the horizon
if halo is something you've enjoyed in
the past and you don't have the mcc yet
do yourself a favor and grab it
asap if halo isn't something you've
gotten the chance to enjoy
i can't underscore how fantastic the
bungie catalog of halo is
and you get access to all of it with the
new features maps and dev support in the
mcc
plus halo 4 is pretty cute too from
arguably the greatest video game sci-fi
epic in its campaign to a very
fan-made content-fueled multiplayer to
an almost endless creative realm in
theater and forge mode halo
has it so you should cop it i'm very
clearly biased to this franchise
but to be fair it is also a titan of the
genre and the medium as a whole
[Music]
you